Sẽ hai bị chính chỗ bên ngờ lòng thành xuống vực khiến một hành khác từ vòng.
Sáng người bẩy thằng năm, Sẽ khác trả trên tình lộ một tâm tắm theo hướng mình ăn chim quá,
khi qua sã mình ăn tình tuyên quan bất ngờ lòng xuống vực sâu gần mấy mẹt,
cú rơi mạnh khiến đầu và đuổi uto biến dạng nghiêm trọng, kính tránh gió vừa nát,
thời điểm sảy ra tay nạn trên Sẽ có hành người trong đó nằm hành khác từ vòng tại chỗ tại sẽ bị thường.
Đoạn đường ngờ giống má thóng luôn mà,
chỉ hơi giống thương tự trơn ở đây thì tổ qua mưa,
tế có một thành phùa Sẽ nào cả,
tục Sẽ nào giống đi vướng vào một cái gì cả.
Sẽ mấy cái bình kia sáng từ nay nó bị cảm đồ sống,
nhưng tế là đến gái phục tìm nóp bảo gần này.
Đến trở cùng mấy lượng cứu hộ dùng mấy xúc và Sẽ chuyên dụng đưa uto gặp nạn Linh Khoai Vực Để Điều trang miền nhần.